world political leaders and religious
leaders calling for peace and
de-escalation in the Middle East after a
wave of deadly attacks the Bloodshed has
heightened fears of broader conflict
during the convergence of Ramadan
Passover and Easter MTS Tire reports
from Tel Aviv
it was chaos on the streets of Israel's
largest city this surveillance video
shows a white car racing down Tel aviv's
popular seafront before flipping over
police then opened fire killing the
driver who's been identified by Israeli
police as a Palestinian citizen of
Israel well this is as close as Israeli
police will allow us but I can see
investigators trying to piece together
what happened at Italian man Alessandro
perini from Rome was killed and five
other British and Italian tourists were
injured a few hours earlier two British
Israeli sisters were killed in a
shooting near an Israeli settlement in
the occupied West Bank their mother
seriously injured the suspected
Palestinian gunman still at Large
the attacks come amid soaring tensions
which saw Israel bomb the Gaza Strip
early on Friday and sites deep inside
Lebanon the Israeli strikes come after a
barrage of rockets were fired from
inside Lebanese territory into Northern
Israel on Thursday the biggest flare-up
there since 2006.
the rocket attacks from both Lebanon and
Gaza followed two consecutive nights of
Israeli raids on the Al-Aqsa mosque
soldiers were filmed inside beating
Palestinians with batons and the butt of
their rifles triggering Fury across the
region although Friday prayers at alaksa
known to Jews as the Temple Mount passed
largely without incident
this weekend devotees from the three
faiths will Converge on Jerusalem's Old
City to Mark Easter Passover and Ramadan
as worshipers pray a fragile peace will
hold over the holiday period
now this week's spiraling violence
follows months of political unrest
inside Israel with mass protests against
prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu and
his extreme far-right government's plans
to overhaul the Judiciary protests which
are set to resume tonight for CBS
Saturday morning imtiaz time Tel Aviv